I'm about to continuing in
wages
of Siam.
Book of fasting.
In the chapter regarding.
Siam and I am and many and her. The
days.
That the prophet
Alihi Wasallam.
Prohibited.
A person fast.
So we've mentioned.
Or the author has mentioned has listed
six days so far.
Six times.
When a person is not permitted to fast.
There's actually eight.
In total.
So we have two more.
Let's see if we can list the first six.
So.
The first six.
Times when a person is prohibited of
fasting or or six days.
Let's go. Huh?
Juma one Farid.
So fasting Friday on its own.
The days of Tashriq, so 11, 12, and 13th
of Dhul-Hijjah.
Al-Eidain, the two days of Eid.
Saturday alone, okay?
Right.
So, the second half of Sha'ban. Right,
the second half of Sha'ban liman lam
takun lahu ada, for a person who doesn't
usually doesn't have a a scheduled fast
then during those times. Okay, one more.
Word it a little better.
Yawm ash-Shakk.
The day
the the dubious time before Ramadan, the
right before Ramadan when
it's it's not necessarily the day
before Ramadan. If it were the day
before Ramadan, and let's say you fast
every Monday and Thursday, and the day
before Ramadan happens to be a Monday,
you can fast that day. Happens to be a
Thursday, you can fast that day. Yawm
ash-Shakk is specifically the day
when the moon
was not sighted because of cloud
coverage or because of something. It
could have been, but we're not sure.
And so, for that reason we're still
looking for the moon, so now it is
called Yawm ash-Shakk, right? And it's
referred to as the day of the doubtful
day because a person is doubtful of
whether or not it is the 30th day
of Sha'ban or it is the first day of
Ramadan. This is the reason that it has
this name. Okay, seven and eight.
So, let's see we can get through the
last two.
or actually seven.
Yeah, seven. One more.
Yaqulu Mu'allif, "Sawmu ad-Dahr
The final day or the final time when a
person is prohibited from fasting
it's actually
very easy to remember and that is
fasting every
other day
than the ones that have been listed.
So, siyam ad-dahr meaning fasting the
entire year, every single day.
Even
if you break your fast on those days
which we had just discussed.
So, if a person were to say, "I'm going
to fast every day, all the time. I'm
never going to break my fast except on
the days when specifically I've been
commanded to break my fast." So, those
first six that we mentioned.
Still, this is a prohibited thing to do.
It is not permissible to fast every
single day of the entirety of the year.
[Silence]
Abdullah ibn Amr
ibn al-As, may Allah be pleased with him
and his father, he narrates to us in
Bukhari and Muslim that the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alayhi wasallam said to
me, "Now, remember Abdullah ibn Amr
he is the one that
his father had noticed that
he was fasting every single day. He was
praying the entirety of the night and
reciting the Quran every single day.
Now,
that's extreme.
You want to say extremism,
right? That is too much. That's extreme.
And it didn't come from a place of
desperation, didn't come from a place of
I want to prove myself, you know, young
man, a lot of times.
They want to They want to make a point
and try to find their identity in the
world. It didn't come from that place.
It came from a place of true passion and
love and fear of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Yet, in spite of that, not all
good intentions are necessarily
necessarily
you know, produce the correct actions.
And it being upon the Sunnah isn't even
enough. It has to be
in the way that the Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam did it.
And so,
Abdullah ibn Amr,
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said to him, so he's narrating to us, he
said to me,
"Oh Abdullah son of Amr,
indeed you
I you know, I've come to know that you
fast every day, all year, year round,
and you pray all night, every night.
And if you do this,
this will negatively affect your body."
He says, "Hajamat al-ain wa nahakat."
Al-ain
hajamat,
meaning that
his eyes will start to suck in. He will
start to look emaciated,
and the light in a person's eyes will
start to
go out or dim,
right? Because it it it literally sucks
the life out of you. And And the thing
is is that
we live in a world of contrast.
When can we appreciate the daytime?
Only if we experience night.
When do we appreciate joy and happiness?
Only if we have
instances of sadness.
We live in a place of contrast. And so
if we fast every single day,
there's no contrast left.
The The lessons that we are to learn
from fasting are no longer as obvious.
The same thing with prayer at night. If
a person never has
sleep at night,
then they will lose the contrast that is
intended by standing in prayer at night.
And so,
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
then says, and this statement is where
the prohibition comes from. He says, "La
sawma
[Arabic recitation]
sawma man sam al-abad. Lannu mush sayim
al-an."
He says, "A person who fasts every day
is not fasting at all."
Right?
What does that mean? we just
mentioned, there is no contrast anymore.
There is no fasting and and not fasting
contrast there anymore.
And if everyone were to do this,
right?
In Islam, we don't have special rules
for special people.
Right?
This is This is how
the people of the book before us went
astray.
One of the ways
is that they had special rules for
special people.
If you're a scholar or if you're a
righteous person, you have special set
of rules.
But if another person is not a scholar,
then they can break all those rules.
That doesn't exist in Islam.
What applies to one applies to all. And
what is permitted for one is permitted
for all.
So, we have to imagine in any of the
laws of Islam, if everyone were to do
this or the majority of people were to
do this, what would happen to the Muslim
state? What would happen to the Muslim
people?
Everyone is fasting every single day and
everyone is praying all night every
single night. What would occur?
this is unsustainable.
And so,
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
[Arabic recitation]
Ghadiba
Mamnu'ul ghadab, sah?
Mamnu'ul ghadab?
[Arabic recitation]
Hadha Hadha mush bashar, hadha.
I don't know.
I don't know. I know. I don't I don't
know. I don't I don't know.
I don't I don't
I don't know.
I don't
I don't I don't I don't
I don't I don't I don't I don't
I don't I don't
I don't
I don't I don't I don't
Abu Qatada narrates
that a man came to the prophet
and said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
how do you fast?"
Right? And so, the messenger of Allah
became visibly angry
from what this man had said. And Omar
was present and when he noticed the
prophet's
anger, he said audibly, "We are sufficed
with Allah as our Lord, with Islam as
our religion, and with Muhammad as our
prophet. We seek refuge in Allah from
the anger of Allah and from the anger of
the messenger of Allah." And he
continued to repeat this
[Arabic recitation]
the prophet calm again, until he calmed
down.
And so, the messenger of
[Arabic recitation]
question.
He corrected the question. He said, "Oh
messenger of Allah,
what is the ruling for a person who
fasts every single day of the year?"
The prophet
said,
"He has neither fasted nor has he broken
his fast."
He has neither fasted nor has he broken
his fast. Meaning he has neither fasted
Islamically, legislatively,
in the Sharia of Islam, this is not
fasting. He has not fasted, which means
that it is not valid.
Nor has he broken his fast. Meaning
physically he's not broken his fast. So
he's in this bizarre valley between two
places.
He's neither fasting nor has he broken
his fast. And that valley
is the valley where many people will
lose their fight with the Shaitan. Why?
Because they are not sufficed with the
Sunnah of the prophet
Alihi Wasallam.
The question is why did the
messenger of Allah
become angry with this question? Because
the question insinuates that it's not
enough.
The question insinuates that
you know,
we could physically fast every single
day and even the messenger of Allah
could fast every single day. It's as if
he has
he
He viewed his fasting, fasting every
Monday, every Thursday, fasting 3 days a
month, fasting
that this is not enough. Could be more,
should be more, right?
And so for this reason
was saying
what he said and reframed the question
as what's the ruling for someone who
goes beyond your fasting? What's the
ruling for someone who fast the entirety
of the year?
He said,
"He has not fasted nor has he broken his
fast. This person is in a lose-lose
situation."
[Arabic recitation]